i know you love joe manchin and we we've
all talked we all like joe manchin he's
i think he's literally held this country
together i think the reason why
the united states is joe manchin and to
a lesser uh degree
he's a constitutional right yep now what
do you think about the nons as a
democrat what do you think about
the hard push from the left to get him
out of the party to get him pushed out
you see it literally every day if you
look up your mansion look at look at
slate
look at uh uh mother jones look
at at all of the democrats look at what
aoc says about him
look at what they say about him look it
from his own side
i'm just gonna use james carville's
words not i mean my i'm not that
far left so to to don't loot me in there
but i'm just gonna use james carville's
words
and he basically said this woke left
needs to go
james carville was clinton's right-hand
man you know the raging cajun
he's married to a republican divorce
okay well sorry about that you know good
luck but brilliant brilliant political
opportunity yeah
brilliant political his most famous line
is like tell me what you didn't like
about the 90s with clinton the peace or
the prosperity
which one you don't like peace you don't
like prosperity he basically said
democrats are getting a bad name because
50 to use his numbers 15 percent
of the democrats are this woke
left canceled culture yada yada yada aoc
you know 15 again these are his words
he said the majority of democrats are
suburban women blacks college educated
people that
don't necessarily agree with that now
i know you said well don't talk about
both sides he basically said
there's a way more than fifteen percent
on the republican side that are maggot
out
that are completely they don't think
january sixth democratic political
operative said this yeah okay
correct exactly so to answer your
original question
yes there's going to be people on the
left that want to get mansion out of
there
but common sense wins at the end of the
day i think pat always talks about
the best ideas will always win those are
elected officials i'm talking about i'm
not talking about the the
the crazies that are out there you know
what
you just said about manchester united
pull up the video on uh what he
what she just said about mansion kai i
just emailed it to you it's uh with
chris hayes i think is it chris hayes
is that his name chris hayes on the next
is on msnbc kai did you get the email i
sent you another bastion of journalistic
integrity but you know what i don't
think that a lot of
like people that support trump i don't
think they're trump's pull up trump
stirs
as much as their anti-establishment as
much as around yeah i mean
i agree with i mean bro he's a brave
owner uh he's a brave heart he's a brave
artist
i think they're trumpsters bro of course
well when we when you've been
governed by the left for so long and do
you think they love trump are they
covered by the left he really loves
that what i'm saying do you think they
love trump or do you think that they
hate
the the political establishment just
look at his approval ratings bro
just look at the numbers what's trump's
approval ratings with the republican
party oh no 90
yeah yeah it's crazy so yeah they love
him okay here we go
look at this idiot aspect of this is
that
hr1 stands up against lobbyists
and dark money and i would reckon to
think
that this is probably just as much a
part
of joe manchin's calculus as anything
else
because when it comes to this bipartisan
argument
i gotta tell you i don't buy it because
joe manchin has voted for bills
that have not been bipartisan before
look at the american rescue plan
so this is not just about bipartisanship
this is
i think because you look at the koch
brothers
and you look at you know organizations
like the heritage foundation
and conservative uh lobby groups that
are doing a victory lap
claiming victory over the fact that
mansion
refuses to change on the filibuster
and i think that these two things are
very closely intertwined
and i think that there's a desire to
make this just about he disagrees with
me
protecting the franchise but protecting
our democracy
is also about making sure that we give
lobbyists and dark money groups
which are funding these attacks on the
right to vote
the boot get rid of the filibuster you
know to protect democracy
very very tight grip on both parties
and i think that that has partnered with
i think that i get a freaking
headache listening to this idiot bro i'm
going to buy you a rookie card of aoc
no
you gave me many gifts i promise you
this is going to be the only one that's
going to go through your
no i would no it would go straight to my
fireplace you should give it to adam
she's
that's she's a babe though right bro i
don't i don't
bro she's an idiot if she were ugly no
but he would be listening to her that's
my opinion
of course that's right nobody listens to
bernie
she's sanders not horrible there's
another one that's even worse
not attractive let's let's uh look we're
going to see what's going to happen here
but the whole story went from
where it was at to mansion to aoc to
you know where things are at right now
with larry elder california
it's going to be interesting to see what
happens can a guy
conservative black man win governor in
the state of california
we will find out very soon here and if
he does
does he really have enough time to do
anything about it i don't know can he
get reelected and stay there for another
four years we're gonna see i think
living in california people are just
tired man we just we want we want we
want to change
so bad people don't i don't want to
leave california but i really don't i
love california
and if things change chances are i'm not
gonna leave but if it doesn't change
we're gone so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you